ما كادت تتضح قرارات قضائيه واتخذت قبل
اسابيع بعوده النقابات والاتحادات المهنيه
التي كانت تنشط ابان حكم الرئيس المعزول
عمر البشير حتى اصدر رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان قرارا قضى
بتجميل نشاطات تلك النقابات والاتحادات
المهنيه والاتحاد العام لاصحاب العمل قرار
البرهان اثار الردود الفعل المتباينه
القرار همم
المحكمه العليا
تقريبا
والمجلس السيادي او الحكومه التنفيذيه ما
من حقه يتدخل في قرارات السلطه القضائيه
لكنه هناك من اعتبر قرار التجميد خطوه
نحوه تسويه ملابسات قانونيه وسياسيه وان
النقابات تمثل عنصر مهما في بنيه الفتره
الانتقاليه ووصف اخرون بانه مخرج لازمه
البلاد سياض البرهان بهذا القرار يريد ان
يسلك طريقا ثالثا بين الاحكام القضائيه
وبينما سبق من احكام خاصه باليان تسير هي
محاوله قد تكون ذكيه للخروج من مازق
قانوني بقرارات بعيده عن التدخل في القضاء
عقب سقوط نظام الرئيس المعزول عمر البشير
كانت النقابه والاتحادات المهنيه
السودانيه موضوع جدال بين بقائها او تجميد
نشاطاتها وطبط ذلك الجدل الذي شغل الساحه
السياسيه والقانونيه بمدى مواطنتها
لمتطلبات الفتره الانتقاليه من اجل
التغيير
في مصلحه تسويه بقدر مع انه برده بياكد
الحاله بتاعه التردد المستمره
للانقلاب لانه هو بيدار من اكثر من مركز
ودي مساله خطره حتى على مساله الحل
السياسي
ورغم ان المجلس المركزيه لقوى الحريه
والتغيير لا ينظر بعين ايجابيه لقرار
التجميل الا انه لا يسد الباب امام
امكانيه تمهيد القرار لتسويه سياسيه بين
العسكر والمدنيين
للقاء اتخاذ قرارات من شانها تعطيل احكام
قضائيه امور تثير جدلا بين الفرقين في وقت
تشهد فيه لبلاد الجهودا لتسويه تنهي
الازمه بشقها القانوني والسياسي
الجزيره الخرطوم